got these Jeffrey dimer glasses chill
dude just mention the hotel
okay
by the way would have had so many more
victims because the gay dudes would have
been like [ __ ] yeah let's go dude it
would have been [ __ ] off
you think that Brendan's cuter than
Jeffrey Dahmer oh oh bro this guy's this
guy's thinking about the [ __ ] Series
where the [ __ ] model plays him for
[ __ ] sake the real Jeffrey
looks like Nick it doesn't look like me
wait first of all Nick's not a bad
looking dude all right hold on a second
no Nick you have Richard Ramirez teeth
with Jeffrey Dahmer face
for the Oakland booty
hahaha
Mr Ramirez
by the way isn't it wait that's uh Sir
Sir Mix-A-Lot right can you please put
up a poll you know who's better am I
better looking than Jeffrey Dahmer so
real quick can we just admit that Eric
Griffin is attracted to Jeffrey Dahmer I
know I'm saying that you did though
would you write a comparison It's Like A
or B and I'm not I'm not better looking
than Jeffrey Dahmer
oh look at the second picture right here
right there that's the one right there
Jeffrey Dahmer you know he looks goofy
here maybe is is is fine looking in a
picture there's no picture with Jeffrey
dahmins better look at me by the way I'm
not an L.A I'm not an LA nine all right
by no means am I a nine in L.A compared
to Dahmer though how dare you Eric I
think Dahmer kind of looks like Chris a
little bit that because you know I have
stuff behind my face like where I'm like
he doesn't look like Chris you know I
get cereal no don't bring up that that's
a bad picture my face is there it is
right that right there look at that
let's me no not that one my face is that
that's actually a good picture the one
the the one where I'm in the where I
look like a blackjack dealer with the
vest on Boom
I'm not better looking than him no bro I
I I agree with you bro I I think he's
just equal no dude you're you're at the
gay club Brandon you know you're like
okay you know what Eric is he's dumber
and you're like a hater okay okay let me
see you're seeing Jeffrey Dahmer dance
[Music]
have you seen him dance in the series
we don't know how Jeff Jimmy drummer
could have been like no you're
romanticizing Jeffrey Dahmer because
you're a [ __ ] white it's a problem
you're doing what White Chicks do yeah
I'm sending them letters yeah yeah yeah
cause these white chicks on Tick Tock is
like did you see it though does anybody
else feel sorry for Jeffrey Dahmer it's
like [ __ ] are you he used to eat it's
not even feel sorry the whole serial
killers are hot thing it just drives me
nuts I know me too it's like no you're
saying that because you live in a
fantasy world you don't actually think a
Serial Killer's hot you meet one of
these [ __ ] and they're just
like oh hey hey yeah they don't like
personality well Ted Bundy had a
Charisma anybody that does anything
really well they don't seem to be like a
good husband father uh good whatever
because look what happens you know what
I mean they're just to be great at this
thing friggins
prolific serial killer yeah looking like
Michael Jordan not the best husband or
father right Tom Brady's getting a
divorce it don't seem like he was the
best it might be a good dad though
sounds like a good dad good dad you
don't want to be married to him yeah but
also with Tom rates I can't only have
one headshot in the household that
didn't dim the rules headshot you only
have one head meaning only one person
can be an entertainment
the
rules
my point is that Jeffrey Dahmer is a
fine looking guy and then you hear him
talking stuff and it's worse yeah
because he's on the spec right okay well
the let's not you know nobody again
nothing against people on the Spectrum
you can be on the Spectrum and not
serial kill yeah I don't know it's one
of my favorite shows most of the time
they are really great accountants you
know what I mean Ted buggy could have
been like freaking uh uh the dude that
owned apple or freaking Elon Musk I
don't think so these type of people I
don't think so yeah
I'm saying or he could have been a
comedian you know what I mean like
what's like like Chris is one step away
from like happened imagine the car
window in yeah yeah pulling someone out
having heads in his freaking
refrigerator not all of them but Ted
Bundy was smart like he represent
himself as a lawyer and before they sent
him to death the judge goes you know
it's a shame he goes you've been a
[ __ ] fine uh lawyer this is what I'm
saying man well no he's the only one the
rest of them are morons
it's hard to look but they're the
tenacity and the hard work and the [ __ ]
Dedication that this 14 year old kid was
his boyfriend that's crazy bro and they
and the cops helped him back yeah take
away from there that had a lot to do
with it those cops are stupid homophobia
that had a lot to do with homophobia